all right let's uh let's hear from some
people in the audience this is the last
opportunity before
next week's election want to see what's
on people's minds of course now
using the david pakman show discord
server which you can find
at davidpakman.com slash discord
and lots of great conversation happening
there otherwise
let's first go to uh
let's go to ali from detroit ali from
detroit
you were on uh what's going on there
what's on your mind today
ali from detroit please unmute and you
can talk to me
sorry can you hear me now yes i can oh
i'm a big fan
thank you i'm glad uh i was calling
today
because i i wanted to ask like what do
you think about the filibuster
and what's the likelihood that that will
actually get repealed under
like a biden administration because i
have my doubts that
that the filibuster will leave it will
even be gone but
i uh i have the same doubts i have seen
so
on on expanding the court i now feel
very strongly joe biden should do it i
don't buy the slippery slope arguments i
think it's completely warranted given
the way republicans have dealt with the
supreme court over the last four years
i think it's time and i don't buy as i
mentioned in a commentary earlier this
week that every president then now is
going to expand the court on the
filibuster i've seen
better arguments for both sides but i
think the arguments will be moot because
i like you
don't really think joe biden's going to
going to push for it
oh okay um oh
and another thing i was going to ask you
is um so do you think we could actually
like make a progressive movement through
a biden administration because
i feel like after hearing aoc talk
earlier this week and saying how she's
planning to lobby him
towards her agenda when it comes to
uh fracking i just kind of have my
doubts that she'll even
or that anything like that will get done
well remember joe biden's joe biden's
idea you know
trump has made this big deal out of joe
said he would ban fracking and then joe
said he wouldn't
biden's actual plan is to put us on a
path to get to 100
renewables which would simply phase out
fracking and everybody's focused on
is biden going to try to pass a law to
make it illegal in six months
no he's not going to do that in either
case the point is
a framework where we get away from
fracking anyway
and so i don't see aoc's position as
completely antithetical to biden's
anyway the point is
will will he have the senate and what
can he actually
get through as a result of that i think
it's less about his ambitions than
whether it's actually feasible with the
senate
okay um you know that's that's all i had
to ask you today i'm a big fan i'm glad
i got to talk to you
all right ali from detroit appreciate
hearing from you thank you so much
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure
but also to take control of your
finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman